aujourd'hui on est au complexe sportif
des avirons et nous accueillons donc
quatre écoles différentes
huit classes en tout pour 240 enfants en
fait l'objectif est assez de se
rencontrer et de faire des activités en
commun c'est pas la performance on n'est
pas là pour faire de la compétition
c'est de faire des ateliers apprendre
vivre ensemble
une partie a eu c'est ce qu'il fait en
gros si nos visiteurs et aux signaux
nécessaires au sort do vite été mais la
vérité est celle qu'avait mais bien dans
en fait il ya beaucoup d'ateliers mis en
place et des ateliers de sports
innovants comme le kin-ball tube all
nous avons aussi des ateliers de sport
et handicap comme la boccia le tord
balle la sarbacane l'infrastructure
change par exemple n'ont pas des fois
des stades à proximité de leur école ils
ont du matériel qu'ils n'ont pas à
l'école et ensuite je veux dire quand on
est dans une hutte dans une école on se
rend compte à deux trois classes et là
c'est quand même une manifestation avec
plus d'enfants
enfin la transporte ensuite déçu
et
allez on fait deux équipes on peut
essayer les filles contre les garçons
allez c'est parti on tire allez les
filles défendez vous allez
ces journées servent à initier les
enfants énormément de jeu collectif à
partager également avec d'autres écoles
d'échangés c'est vraiment le but de
coopérer dans des jeux dans les
activités depuis de se faire plaisir
également sa toutes les valeurs d'entre
elles d'amitié de partage
les enfants sont obligés de coopérer de
se retrouver ensemble de partager
d'échanger d'être en conflit également
aussi sur le jeu uniquement sur le jeu
quand je termine et on devient
partenaire ya pas encore toutes les
écoles qui participent mais énormément
d'écoles quand même y participent
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait encore
développer parce que je pense que c'est
très intéressant niveau du partage pour
tous les enfants
et je crois qu'au niveau socialisation
c'est le plus important donc c'est de
faire du sport c'est bouger quand sa
santé